[Applause]
Sicilians thank police as news emerges
that they have finally arrested Mateo
dinaro Italy's most Wanted Man picked up
at a private Hospital in Sicily's
Capital Palermo a boss of Casa Nostra
the Island's notorious Mafia group
I was incredulous shocked but happy says
this local man dinaro is being kept at a
secret location and is unlikely to see
Freedom again in 2002 he was convicted
in absentia of being involved in crimes
that include bombing attacks the murder
of two State prosecutors and the torture
and killing of a 12-year-old boy
one Sicilian lawmaker told Global News
it is above all a symbolic day for
Sicily I mean the damage that this guy
and these guys have done to the millions
of good Sicilians all over the world
it's enormous why it took 30 years to
find him and how he could have been
hiding in Sicily our questions
authorities need to answer
Italian Prime Minister Georgia Maloney
says it is a day for Italians to
celebrate but insists the war against
the mafia has not been won because
anastra isn't what it was but organized
crime remains a problem in Italy one
notoriously difficult to tackle so now
we have to consider and this is the
basic question what will happen will he
cooperate with the judicial Authority or
not judicial sources say 60 year old
dinaro was being treated for cancer he
was already sentenced to life in jail 21
years ago so there may be little
incentive left for him to reveal the
remaining secrets of Kosen Austra
Redmond Shannon Global News London